I just want to say that I'm actually
incredibly excited to be here with Wyatt
at the Skywalker Ranch it's like to live
long obsessions coming together this is
my office in Copenhagen we're inside a
cow's burg factory where they used to
make the least interesting part of the
beer the bottle cap we're also in New
York these are my American colleagues we
architects but we also do haircuts and
basically the way we work is that we
always try to mine as much information
out of a situation before we intervene
in a way we start looking for what could
be the greatest potential or what could
be the biggest problem and then we use
that information to inform our design
decisions so they're not arbitrary
stylistic choices they're always
informed by something specific and I'll
just give you two examples we did a
sports hall in my old high school and we
could either put it on the football
fields or in the middle of the courtyard
but in Denmark football is the national
sport so it would be like a political
suicide to put it there so we had to dig
it under the courtyard and it's a
handball hole and on the perimeter you
need 15 feet of clearance and in the
middle you need 25 feet of clearance and
actually we got the commission from my
old math teacher so as a sort of homage
we based the architecture of the dome on
the mathematical formula for a ballistic
arch so the sort of a graceful curvature
of the glulam beams is actually shaped
by the mathematics of the sport
everything you see here is actually it's
not designed essentially it's just
simply tracing the sort of a the natural
geometry of a thrown handball and as a
result it leaves an imprint of in the
courtyard it becomes like this informal
furniture that has actually sort of
invited people to start hanging out so
like almost like this or cascade of
effects there's like basic tracing of
the of the mathematics of handball
suddenly creates this this new space in
in the courtyard another example is the
Hamlet's Castle Combe ball north of
Copenhagen
it recently became unesco world heritage
and the Danish Maritime Museum used to
be inside the castle but they had to put
it somewhere else and they suggested put
it inside the drydock where they used to
build ships and it was kind of a dilemma
because UNESCO said that we couldn't
stick out of the ground as much as a
foot to not block the view of the castle
but of course the museum wanted some
kind of an architectural masterpiece to
attract people to come and check it out
so we got this idea to use the museum as
a way of preserving the dock turning the
dock inside out we turn it into a giant
void all we have to do is design a
series of bridges one that stops the
water from coming in one that connects
over to the castle and then one that
sort of takes you down into the museum
we could actually build all of the
bridges in a Chinese shipyard and then
sail them in and click them into place
so in a way the architecture is
completely sort of manifesting all of
the aspects of shipbuilding from the
steel of the bridges to the concrete of
the of the dock you have this sort of
descent through different spaces of
intimate scale on vast scale you get
this like clash of the old and the new
the lightness of the steel and the glass
clashing with the heaviness of the
concrete and anyway the sort of this is
the grown-ups auditorium that sort of
extends under the stage and becomes an
auditorium for the kids the dark extends
into the restaurant and you have this
sort of a holes of coexistence of the
sort of the Shakespearean heritage on
one hand and this is like ultra
contemporary universe below the horizon
the sort of an inverse Titanic moment
looking into a and essentially like like
once we've defined what the key criteria
is like the proximity to the UNESCO
heritage we don't necessarily have the
answer it's just a question we've
formulated so we have to do tons of
models we always have to like make tons
of models to test it and sometimes we
make huge models and sometimes we make
the models out of Lego so like if you
just go around our office everything is
sort of Lego everybody even our signage
is made out of Lego so when we got
approached by Lego actually Lego made
one of our buildings in the Legos
door we're not going to file a suit it's
actually the highest compliment you can
get us an architect but when they
approached us to to look at making a
Lego house which would be sort of
looking at all aspects of culture
through the eyes of Lego we were sort of
incredibly excited
we went completely to town and we really
had to get this job it's going to be
like well Lego is from in in Pilon in in
Denmark and essentially what what really
excites me about Lego is that Lego
empowers children and everyone like
playing with Lego to create their own
world and then to inhabit it through
play and that's exactly what
architecture is supposed to be about
it's in a way of like finding ways to
empower people to influence their
physical environment so that they can
actually live the life they want to live
the Lego house is on a construction this
is me this is like the foundations of
like these concrete Lego bricks this is
me standing with all of the richest
people in Denmark the Lego family and if
you if you can't wait it's going to open
in two years but if you can't wait you
can actually build it yourself but sort
of a way to sort of get people involved
it's this sort of idea of like
crowd-sourced design in a way we did an
urban space in Copenhagen and it's it's
in the most ethnically diverse
neighborhood in all of Denmark it
consists of what we call the Red Square
the black market and the Green Park and
you have sixty different nationalities
living here so the importance of the
project was really to involve the local
community and create a sense of
ownership so we got this idea that it
would be strange if the Danes had done
the best pinch and the best trash bin
and the best lamppost so we reached out
to the local community through different
media and through meetings and had
people recommend elements from their
other home country and the basic idea is
that we don't eat Chinese food to be
nice to the Chinese it's because we
crave Beijing duck or noodles or
dumplings and we didn't put a Moroccan
fountain in the middle of Copenhagen to
be nice to the Moroccans but because
they have an amazing
heritage of architecture water features
so you have a Jamaican sound system the
neighbors hate it a Thai boxing arena
you have Iraqi swings little boxes from
Great Britain bollards from Ghana like
bicycle racks from Finland the sign on
the Red Square is actually a sign from
the Red Square you have like an amazing
Cossack bus stop way cooler than a
typical Danish one we found palm trees
in China but actually grow in a Danish
climate this octopus like really serve
reveals the the diversity of the
neighborhood and the sort of impact of
playing when you look at the benches
this s curved love seed from Mexico
where you can look the person you're
sitting next to into the eyes there's a
Belgian bench where everybody looks away
from each other so and they're like even
down to the lighting we have these neon
signs that advertise stuff you can't buy
in Denmark this is a Qatari dentist like
something from the socialist countries
we even made an app so people can get
the stories of the different objects and
in a way like it really reminds how like
amazing it becomes when you outsource
the creativity to the community to
actually have an massive impact on their
own environment so we took this idea
with us when like you probably remember
like a bit more than two years ago sandy
hit New York and cost a lot of
devastation it wiped out all of lower
Manhattan creating a new neighborhood in
Manhattan South how south of power and
and essentially like suddenly the Sandy
happened because the sort of Atlantic
hurricane build is expanding because of
rising temperatures and because of the
geometry of the New York Bight you have
this sort of 90-degree funnel shape like
all of this sort of storm surge is
channeled into the most densely
populated region in all of America
putting 50% of New York at risk and if
you look at this map of lower Manhattan
you can see since the 17th century we've
been expanding Manhattan through
landfill and this landfill is exactly
the area that is now flood prone so you
can say the areas that we have been
responsible for creating also the ones
where
we need to take greater responsibility
in in protecting them so the question is
like how can you protect all of lo
Manhattan without creating this seawall
that segregates the life of the city
from the water around it and we thought
maybe we could learn a little bit from
the High Line the High Line is a piece
of decommissioned infrastructure that
has now turned into one of the most
popular promenades in New York City we
were thinking like what if you can
actually instead of waiting for the
infrastructure to get decommissioned
before you add the program what if you
could actually think of the resilience
infrastructure for Manhattan as sort of
the dry line to imagine it that it comes
from day one with a lot of extra sort of
sort of positive social and
environmental side effects so when you
look at the flood map you have these
like natural pinch points where the
flooding doesn't get very far into the
island because of the topography so we
use these as a way to create
compartments just like you have
compartments in a ship each compartment
can sort of be sort of solved on its own
and then when you look at the sort of
urban development of New York its
characterized by this David and Goliath
encounter between Robert Moses aka the
power broker and Jane Jacobs Robert
Moses he did a lot of the the necessary
infrastructure investments of Manhattan
like a lot of the highways on the
waterfront a lot of the social housing
projects but they were very very
top-down and they were like really very
sort of instantly successful they often
like cut the people off from like
different neighborhoods got cut off from
each other or like you couldn't reach
the water and one day he tried to cut a
highway through Greenwich Village and he
met Jane Jacobs who mounted this
grassroot opposition and eventually she
defeated the plan and Greenwich Village
is still there but we thought you know
in this case it could be interesting to
think of this resilience infrastructure
as the love child of Robert Moses and
Jane Jacobs because you know to provide
you know eight contiguous miles of
waterfront protections you need holistic
big-picture perspective but it needs to
happen rooted in the local communities
and essentially
the main challenge is to resist a
certain amount of storm search you need
a certain geometry but this geometry
could make could be made in so many
different ways so that when you go there
you won't notice that this is actually
part of a dam it could be like a piece
of landscape that also becomes what
protects the the city from flooding it
could be like various artworks or like
almost like furniture landscaping you
can imagine like the the median of the
West Side Highway could become this art
piece that also sort of protects the the
city from from flooding and as a way to
do this we went a step further we went
to the Lower East Side Louis side was
like really massively hit by by Sandy
these are the areas that got flooded and
when you look at the 100-year flood and
the 500 year flood actually two-thirds
of this neighborhood is is flood
threatened its it's a primarily
residential neighborhood and it's this
is actually a map of all of the public
housing or the affordable housing on
lower Manhattan it's all inside this
neighborhood it's also the most ethnic
diversity board it's the most socially
challenged neighborhood
it's like rather under serviced by by
public transportation but in return it
has a highway cutting it off from from
the waterfront and even though it
appears green it actually has a lot less
Park that any other neighborhood in in
Manhattan 95% of the surface is
impervious which also makes it more
flood prone and when you walk down the
waterfront you can see that it's like
tortured by the sort of relationship to
to the infrastructure so we sort of
created this process where we sort of
reached out to to the local community we
had a series of workshops with the
people from the Lower East Side trying
to test different ideas we made this of
smorgasbord of different solutions and
together we formulated a series of
strategies so because one idea was in
the East River Park simply to create
like raise the ground of the pact to
protect the pact from the north of the
highway and also protect the city from
from flooding it
be a phase one of a phase two to
eventually submerge the park and
integrate a new subway line underneath
it submerge the highway we're sort of
moving the bicycle lanes into the into
the park side the existing bridges that
are these caged highway bridges become
like high lines sort of extending you
know we integrate a DA accessibility
into the natural topography you arrive
in this like sloping pack that takes you
out into the water we're also creating a
10th Street Harbor bath because the
Hudson is actually or the East River so
clean you can swim in it underneath the
FDR we got this idea so actually turn
the underside of the FDR into some like
an asset like you have a lot of spaces
in New York that I actually beautiful
when you look up so we got this idea of
creating these add pieces hanging
underneath the the bridge so you know
normally you just look up and you have
like local artists and you know it
illuminates and make the other side more
friendly and then you know some of them
can flip down and create temporary
enclosures for like a Christmas market
or they can become what what saves the
city some places all you need is
actually four feet of height to resist
the 50-year floodplain so they can be
like undulating benches serving
different activities and then they also
becomes what saves the city and they can
serve as sockets for bigger flood
barriers when you have a 100 year or 500
year flood coming further down we're
proposing to create these little
pavilions that animate the space
underneath the canopy of the of the
highway
so like galleries and markets that sort
of make the underside more friendly and
lively but also protects the the city
from flooding their place so that you
will never block the view from the side
streets coming down to the water so you
always look uninterrupted down to the
water but then you have these like
sliding walls that can come out and
actually stop a flood from coming in and
finally when you reach the south tip of
Manhattan we're working with a battery
pack to create sort of a series of
little events in the pack that creates a
natural topography we're sort of
integrating a new Harbor school and what
we imagined to be a Museum of cities on
the water where the big order
thorium could actually be this like
inverse aquarium giving you a view into
the different flood lines of different
storms so essentially the thinking is to
take all of the hard infrastructure that
is necessary to protect Manhattan from
flooding but then to always design it in
close dialogue with the different
residents of the different communities
so that as you move around you won't
sense that we've sort of incarcerated
Manhattan in a flood wall but we've
actually sort of reanimated Manhattan so
that when the next Santa comes it's
going to remain a lively city this
project has just been sort of granted
three hundred thirty five million
dollars from the federal government so
we're going to start phase one but but I
often get the objection that this is a
little bit too much like science fiction
so just to give you an example of what
we call social infrastructure that is
actually happening right now this is
downtown Copenhagen we're doing a
waste-to-energy power plant that
basically turns trash into electricity
and district heating when you look at it
as a resource one ton of trash equals
one and two thirds of an oil barrel in
terms of energy so it's a really
valuable resource but the they operate
on an economy of scale so they're ugly
boxes that cast shadows on the neighbors
and block the views this is going to be
the biggest and tallest building in
Copenhagen so it's going to be right
next to the marina and it's going to be
right where the local boys go
waterskiing so we thought like in
Denmark we love skiing we have snow but
we have absolutely no mountains but we
do have mountains of trash so we thought
we have to go to Sweden for four hours
to Iza bail but because of the sheer
magnitude of this power plant we can put
2/3 of Iza bail on top of the power
plant we know how big the machines are
so we decide in this like sloping roof
that has like an elevator takes you to
the top of a bit green a blue and a
black ski slope we plant trees on top of
the column so it really becomes like a a
man-made Mountain insanely we won the
competition based on this idea so
suddenly we we had to figure it out
just to give you a sense of scale you
can see this is an Olympic halfpipe so
some of you might have noticed that
Denmark got zero medals in in Sochi
we hope to change that because now we
can actually practice at home also for
the people not skiing there's a hiking
path you can do picnics you can enjoy
the view of your otherwise completely
flat City we're including the tallest
climbing wall in the world 300 feet for
those who have the balls and basically
like the reason we could win the
competition based on this idea like it's
essentially turning the whole power
plant into this man-made ecosystem where
not only do we locally exploit the
resources also together with the city of
Copenhagen it becomes like an urban
metabolism but the reason we could win
it was because this is going to be the
cleanest waste-to-energy power plant in
the world the smoke coming out of the
chimney is completely non-toxic it only
contains a little bit of co2 and some
steam so that's why you actually have
fresh mountain air on top of this power
plant normally you want to be as far
away from a power plant as you can here
it's actually completely clean but
finally as a way to completely we we
sort of configure the perception of a
power plant we've worked with the
realities United and Copenhagen
suborbitals to design the chimney in a
special way so that basically it's steam
and when like at regular intervals it
puffs a gigantic smoke ring
so essentially something that used to be
a symbol of pollution becomes something
playful of course we couldn't find a
smoke ring contractor so we've been
struggling quite a bit with figuring out
how to do this and just to finish off we
we recently did a test at the end of
August trying to figure out how to do
this and this is how it went
we got addicted so yeah so I think maybe
like the
I mean I just think this let this smoke
ring is maybe like a good symbol of what
architecture is is really all about
because it is somehow this idea like it
has this element of world-changing that
you take something that is like a wild
idea like pure fiction and then you
suddenly turn it into to hide fact and I
really like this idea that you know like
when we came with this idea it everybody
felt like that's insane
but then like in 2017 that's just how it
is you know people who say like in
Venice people say in gondolas through
streets of water and they New York
people sort of inhabit the resilience
infrastructure like pavilions or parks
and in Denmark people ski on their power
plants and they they puff giant rings of
steam so in a way I get HR at its best
it's really the the power to turn you to
make the world a little bit more like
our dreams thanks